la france est en train de battre un
record dans son histoire celui des jeux
d'argent un nouveau jeu national
patronné par l'état donc a en effet
aujourd'hui commencé sa carrière après
la loterie nationale le pmu avec ses
jeux simples ses couplets s'est jumelée
ses triplés c'est hier c est maintenant
s'écarter voici aujourd'hui le loto
depuis ce matin les habitants de la
région parisienne peuvent tenter leur
chance à ce nouveau jeu d'argent en se
procurant les bulletins spéciaux dans
600 bureaux à l'enseigne du loto
généralement des bars tabac ce qui dit
on a fait tiquer madame simone veil le
ministre de la santé
c'est seulement à l'automne que ce jeu
devrait être étendu à une partie de la
province
le centre le val de loire la région
rhône alpes et les départements qui
bordent la méditerranée
le loto va-t-il plaire aux français
peut-être est-ce un peu compliqué faites
vous même une opinion l'argent de poche
il faut en trouver 200 millions lourd
pour équilibrer le budget 76
l'an dernier les courses quotidiennes
ont rapporté à l'état quelques 250
milliards d'anciens francs
l'hebdomadaire le prix national
seulement 16 milliards d'anciens francs
le récent carte et ne semble pas
justifié les espoirs qu'il suscite est
ce là après l'augmentation du tiercé de
3 à 5 francs et celle du couple
résultat toujours aussi médiocre puisque
depuis le 1er janvier la baisse au
tiercé ceci dit toujours autour de 12%
le loto rétablir at-il la situation
ce jeu existe déjà dans 22 pays
capitalistes ou socialiste ainsi en
allemagne en hongrie
il a même dépassé le chiffre d'affaires
de la loterie nationale depuis un
certain temps les émetteurs de 10 yens
de la loterie nationale constatait une
certaine désaffection du public qu'ils
habitent leurs formules et ce sont eux
qui ont commencé à envisager un jeu
nouveau ce jeu nouveau est pour objet de
répondre aux aspirations et publics qui
souhaitent pouvoir choisir ce numéro
c'était aussi un petit peu pour répondre
aux aspirations de monsieur fourcade qui
cherche désespérément de l'argent de
puff
non pas du tout le ministre de
l'économie et des finances également le
gouvernement
autoriser cette formule lorsqu'elle leur
a été proposé mais ce n'est pas la mise
l'économie et des finances qui a pris
l'initiative de cette création
attention il n'est pas possible de se
procurer des bulletins pour jouer au
loto sans acheter en même temps un
billet de la loterie nationale
une grille simple de 6 numéros coûte 1
franc mais la mise minimale est fixée à
2 francs pour deux greer 4 francs pour 4
greer 6 francs pour six grilles 8 francs
pour 8 grisha grille ne comportant que
six numéros mais il y a aussi déjoué
multiples et vous pouvez jouer jusqu'à
dix numéros qui coûte 210 francs
le principe du jeu est très simple il
faut trouver 6 numéros sur une grille de
49 au tirage
contrairement au tiercé l'ordre de
sortie des numéros n'a pas d'importance
tout gagné 6 3 devant numéro sort ou
gagner plus s'il en sort 4 ou 5 ou le
super gros lot 6 mais attention au loto
6 numéros sur 49 représente à peu près
14 millions de combinaisons
c'est en effet une chance en 14 millions
mais ceci prouve que le champ des
possibilités le champ de la liberté
offert aux joueurs est considérable et
je voudrais également au fait remarquer
que pour trouver trois numéros sur 49 à
l'intérieur des 6 tiré au sort c'est
beaucoup plus facile puisque s'ils
représentent une chance sur 50
il s'agit donc de choisir à présent six
numéros pour la simplicité de la chose
je choisis donc la numéro 1 ainsi que la
finale 2 c'est-à-dire le 2 le 12 le 22
le 32e et le 42
il ne reste plus à présent qu'à le faire
venir
nous avons reconstitué un tirage mais
bien entendu nous avons aidé le sort
pour obtenir les six numéros choisis
chose impossible lors de tirages réel 3
seulement de nos numéros choisis sorte
nous gagnons un rapport de 5e rang c'est
à dire le plus petit rapport avec quatre
numéros sortis le rapport sera de 4e
rang 5 numéros troisième rang et enfin 6
numéros le gros lot le rapport sera de
premier rang il existe également un lot
de consolation pour les approchant du
gros lot un rapport de deuxième rang
obtenu avec le tirage d'un septième
numéro appelé le 7 de dr les tirages
auront lieu tous les mercredis les
rapports seront publiés 48' rappelé